[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the pods
moving in storage studio it's the ramsey
show where debt is dumb cash is king and
the paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice we help people build wealth do
work that they love and create real
amazing relationships
rachel cruz ramsey personality number
one best-selling author my daughter is
my co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
that's triple eight eight two five five
two
so rachel uh if people are coming late
to the party last week we did announce
that we have a new
studio sponsor pods moving and storage
to which people might say why yeah would
pods moving in storage beyond a zoo
ramsey show you want to be on the ramsay
show well i mean who wouldn't want to be
on
that
that's the question but uh everybody
would but why would we allow someone to
be here
that we announce and broadcast for and
uh promote
uh a it's a wonderful company and the
people that are in leadership
is one of the things we always look at
when we're doing an endorsement because
if bad people are in leadership
eventually the company's going to turn
bad and so we don't want to put our name
on them so these are people that are
we've known and uh the the cmo the team
there is absolutely incredible but
that's not enough it would need to bring
value to pods and it would need to bring
value to you the listener to put a
little moving truck thing up behind
rachel's head there and so yeah look at
that had one of those out in the parking
lot full size todd's container i got to
stand in it got my picture made it was
good it's a lot of fun 23 people 23
million people move in the u.s each year
one in five ramsey listeners tell us
they plan to move this year and uh pods
is a way to do it efficiently they will
set the pod on your driveway leave it
there as long as you need them to pick
it up and when they pick it up they pick
it up with a podzilla so it's picked up
level they don't tilt it and all your
stuff slide to the back and crash into
each other and break everything they
pick it up level set it on there if your
closing on your new house didn't go
right or something and you need to store
it for a little while you can
now if you do that with a regular moving
company oh
they're going to unpack the truck
and put it in storage and then repack
the truck and the cost is unbelievable
so lots of flexibility with these guys
it's an economical way to do the move
you control the speed of the move and we
are proud to have uh they you know
they've had six million moves now at
pods it's not a small they've grown a
lot and i feel like i see them
everywhere yeah they are everywhere and
they've done a great job with their
marketing but their service is
incredible
um we got to meet
the local guy that's one of the drivers
the drivers that bring the pod to your
house and pick them up are employees
they're not contract so they work for
the team and they take great care for
that podzilla to operate properly and
will from antioch you know just over the
hill over here broad hours over here we
got to meet him and he had a great
financial peace university story been
through fpu so
good stuff and it's a good way to do
this so we're excited to have pods as
the new sponsor for the studio you'll be
hearing more about that in the coming
weeks and days as we let you know more
and more things about it but it's a good
thing kevin starts off this hour in
nashville hey kevin welcome to the
ramsay show
hey mr ramsay hey what's up
um so
23 years old and um ever since i was
about 17 i've
been sports betting and
it's just gotten worse and worse and
worse and i've i'm i'm in ga now and i
see a therapist and
nothing really seems to work and i'm
just feeling really really defeated and
you know hopeless and i was just
wondering if you had any wisdom you
could share advice
i'm sorry man
that's a hard thing yeah
it's the worst thing that's ever
happened to me ever for
people in america that don't understand
the fastest the second fastest growing
addiction in north america today is not
cocaine or fetanol or prescription drugs
or alcohol it is
gambling online
fastest growing addiction second fastest
growing addiction first is porn
and uh we deal with we deal with these
numbers because we deal with people's
lives that are broken around their
finances all the time
due to this kind of stuff so we've
talked to
over 30 years a whole lot of people
where kevin is and kevin i'm not an
addictions expert by any stretch you
know that right
absolutely yes sir all right so how long
have you been going to ga
um about three months and i've known
that i should have been going a lot
longer but i mean past is the past you
learned that in ga
all we do i don't worry about tomorrow's
a new day right
yeah one baby step at a time right
and so are you making all your meetings
are you
yep
going
go twice a week um at two different
locations so and i also see a therapist
that specializes in it but
for some reason it's just it's just so
hard even with all of these things in
place so
oh no it's not gonna be easy um it is
very hard that's why we call it an
addiction and not a problem
right
if it was a problem you could work
through it it's an addiction and so it's
gonna it's it's got its claws deep into
your soul and you're having to work
you're going to pry them out a little
bit at a time so is your therapist
moving the needle
um definitely improvements i mean like i
said i've been gambling for five years
and i will go you know a few days or a
week or two now which if you told me a
year ago
that could happen i would say it's
impossible
um i just haven't been able to fully
kick it like you said just the nature of
addiction i guess but
it is the nature of it but we have to
obviously write a new script for the
future which is part of why you're
calling
um so what is the environment in which
you're are you online fanduel or
whatever
yeah so it's it's online and i have you
know casinos close by that that take
bets and bookies and it's like you know
every everywhere i look i could gamble
it just that's just how it feels so
[Music]
okay what do you do for a living and i'm
tired of
yeah so um i work for the government and
um i have a college degree and i make 70
grand a year
and that just makes me feel even more
worthless because no one my age should
be struggling i should be you know doing
the baby steps and here i am just
fueling a betting account with every
paycheck and
you know that's just like the worst part
of it are you in are you in debt kevin
because of the addiction
um yes thankfully not not too much but i
have about five thousand dollars worth
of credit card debt because just
recently they let you just put it on a
credit card now the only thing okay in
the last two weeks where did you place
your bets
um all online
okay
so what do we do to cut that source off
yeah so i
i've excluded myself from um like the
ones that are like legalized like you
know this like sandal and stuff like
that but the issue for me is just that
there's a thousand just online offshore
you know oh yeah you can bet
yeah
how do we turn your computer off is what
i'm asking
for your phone
yeah is that your phone i guess dripping
me stripping me of electronics might
actually
well i mean for a while i'd be okay with
that because if you're drunk you can't
hang out in a bar right
yeah you're right and like i said not
only affected me financially it's every
relationship i have and you know my work
it's just i just feel so defeated yeah
and usually kevin what we find too is
that the addiction is a symptom and so
dealing with that symptom is really
important like what dave is saying but
also hopefully your therapist is getting
to the point of understanding
what's motivating that like right like
wanting that high what what that is
giving you is for a reason and so doing
that personal work and digging in
to those things which i hope your
therapist is doing to get to the root
cause is
is huge you know i'd also plug into a
celebration recovery class in a local
church and get plugged in and start
walking this on a spiritual angle as
well
that'd be my next thing man i wish i
could be more help i'm not an expert but
we'll pray for you and cry with you
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and churchill is here to help go to
their site
churchillmortgage.com ramsey to start
your approval or get more information
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
guys we really value the input from
people who watch and listen to the
ramsey show it helps us know what's
important to you so we can deliver the
right content that will help you with
the questions and challenges you have
right now one way you can share your
thoughts with us is by answering a few
questions in a new survey we just
launched and you can check it out at
ramseysolutions.com
survey takes just a few minutes and
you'll be in the running for a 500 visa
gift card that someone that takes the
survey will win ramsey solutions dot com
slash
survey
rachel cruz ramsey personality is my
co-host today uh let's circle back
rachel neither you nor i know enough
about addictions uh i wish john deloney
was here today uh but to uh speak
intelligently into it there's a few
things we do know from having worked
with addicts
over the years um
you know
one is you do need to plug into a group
and ga he called it was gamblers
anonymous is what that stands for it's
like alcoholics anonymous but for
gamblers
is uh is incredible uh celebrate
recovery is an incredible ministry with
a christian uh purely christian
perspective and plugging into a good
church is a
wonderful group and process to plug into
and certainly the one-on-one therapist
which is what he's doing is there um
nga you need a a strong or in celebrate
recovery you want a strong sponsor
and the sponsor is the person who is
going to love you
when you fall down but they're also
going to kick your butt and hold you
accountable and talk you off the ledge
so to speak metaphorically
and uh you know that that having those
people in your life matters and then
what you said before we went into the
break is vital that you dig into
the root cause
because the gambling is uh the drinking
the gambling the cocaine use the
whatever the
surface addiction is there's always
something under it
that's uh that's causing it and that is
always a a mental uh health thing uh
it's a childhood thing it's a
spiritual thing and it may be all of
those yeah um it probably is all of
those and so you know as people of faith
we also
have watched our lives be transformed by
our faith walk
and by plugging into a good church and
setting up a new group of friends that
weren't the old friends i mean you can't
run around with drinking buddies anymore
if you got a drinking problem and so if
uh kevin's running around with a bunch
of guys that are still running fanduel
every day and all they're talking about
is football right and
their fantasy league and they're betting
on this and they're betting on that and
so forth and
um you know you got to you got to change
your environment as well and then do
set something up take the stuff off the
apps off your phone or set the phone
down for a period of time or whatever it
is whatever you're using to access
that you've got to reset those things
but that won't work eventually you'll
find your way back to it if you don't
get down under the route and find it
yeah and really dig into that and that's
some
anytime any of us go through and we all
do
a transformation at the character level
at the spiritual level it's painful
yes people do it to get out of debt
they do it
in their marriages they do it recovering
from their childhoods it's painful
there's nothing no pain quite like
emotional pain mm-hmm
but it's necessary
for the change because there is
something to that
uh and again i wish john was here
sitting here because he's like the
licensed therapist but but to them like
to the spirit to the spiritual side
which we both have the same faith walk
um
there's a point in our human condition
that like when there's a little bit of
that surrender of like i can't just keep
pulling myself up by my bootstraps over
and over like there has to be a
transformation that occurs and i think
when you can pinpoint that whether it's
on a spiritual side
but also the emotional side right what
are the things going on where's like the
the anger the hurt the things in your
life
that could be part of the thing that
that's triggering this uh what are
events in your life that have shaped who
you are uh that you kind of go back to
these places of habit that you don't
even realize for protective strategies i
mean like we are just complex people and
i feel like
more and more we uncover that and money
ends up being a symptom for so much of
that that's why here on the ramsey show
like we talk about this stuff a lot not
just addiction but
um but the heart issues of what's going
on and our money is a tool in life that
ends up being affected because of it but
um
but it's it but it can be a dark really
hard spot but i do just want to applaud
kevin for even calling and asking the
question because
uh you could hear it and let me tell you
this kevin i will tell you that um i've
seen a lot of people be successful yes
and walking away from this
uh we see a lot of success
uh there's other things that are
even harder to break i know this is hard
i'm not diminishing this but i mean uh
meth is and heroin are just dad gum the
percentages are very low that you get
out of that alive
uh but gambling people can walk away
from porn they can walk away from they
with help and with treatment and the you
know engaging in the process and uh it
is a spiritual walk it's popping in my
head so i'm just gonna say it um
uh max lucado's no book new book help is
here he was on yesterday talking about
it and uh it's about the holy spirit and
the power of the holy spirit and kevin
i'm gonna recommend that to you and
another one is heinz feet and high
places
that um is a very interesting read when
you're in the soup
and you are you're fighting out of the
soup right now and we're here for you
man you call we'll talk to you anytime
we love you
and um
and you know we're not going to pull any
punches with you we're going to tell you
the truth
but um you're not alone we're going to
walk with you but um but also we're not
going to tell you that we have all the
answers because we certainly don't
thank you for the call though
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five you jump in we'll
talk about your life and
your money patrick is with us in
montgomery alabama
except i pushed the wrong button now i
did patrick's in montgomery alabama hey
patrick what's up
hey how you doing mr ramsey better than
i deserve how can i help
well so a quick background we have about
40 acres and a cabin in north carolina
and my grandmother had owned it since
the 60s after she passed away she gave
it to my mother to take care of
she's been the sole caretaker for the
last 30-something years
and
she's getting up in age and so she's
thinking about trying to you know figure
the plan for the way ahead and the only
concern i have is she's thinking about
splitting up the control over
herself
and trickled down to me and my little
brother and then her three sisters
now with her having taken care of it for
the last 30 something years there hasn't
been really any arguments whenever
something comes up that needs to be done
or taken care of because she's been the
single point of failure and then
everything's taken care of or resolved
does she own it with her sisters
no it is all in my mother's name okay so
why does she feel obligated to drag them
into this mess
well
do you know anything about the
temperament uh orange gold green and
blue yeah yeah
okay well she's a she's a hardcore blue
okay so what she wants to do
is you know that whole family piece and
you know getting everybody happy i think
she feels like if she puts it all in me
or on me
that potentially somebody's feelings
will get hurt
yeah well what but she's mistaken
exactly she's pretty much guaranteeing
with this ridiculous idea that
some feelings are going to be heard all
the time yeah and you're stuck to each
other
so i would tell her mama listen i don't
want in i'm i'll opt out
this is a bad idea mom i love you
and i appreciate what you're trying to
accomplish the way you're doing it i
don't agree with i don't think it's
going to work and i don't want to be
stuck in it
see and everything's paid off and it
doesn't matter my wife and i we follow
doesn't matter my wife has always been
paid off baby steps
yeah it's taken care of and she's got a
little uh
i don't know if you want to call it a
trust but she's got something set up she
said don't worry everything that's not
it for five years after i passed that's
not the problem that's not the problem
yeah if you see a snake kill the snake
don't appoint a committee on snakes
exactly because what i want to do is try
and set it up
so that there's like a
you know vbr or whatever it is so that
basically it acts as a profit and it can
cover the fees and cover all the
expenses and nobody has to worry about
it she said well
that'll have to happen after the sisters
pass away because i don't think they
want to deal with that like well that's
not really their call yeah
yeah
or it is their call because i'm opting
out
so yeah just tell mom no thanks
not going to play this is a barrel of
fish hooks don't stick my hand in it i'm
going to get stuck yep
sorry i love you mom don't love the
cabin don't love yourself sweetheart
though oh she's swimming
she's a golden retriever everybody needs
to be happy together if they're not
happy i'm gonna be stressed and i'm
sorry but you're gonna be stressed
because they're not all gonna be happy
it's part of life oh it's painful this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
still on baby step number one
how'd you guess
with health care costs rising learn how
christian healthcare ministries can help
you make the most out of your budget
visit
chministries.org budget don't worry
it's worth it
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
rachel cruz ramsey personality my
co-host today in the lobby of ramsay
solutions on the debt-free stage may is
with us hi may how are you good good
where do you live san diego wow welcome
to nashville thank you how much debt did
you pay off seventy nine thousand five
hundred dollars seventy nine thousand
yes okay so i'm gonna round that and
call it 80. well done all right and how
long did this take you uh 33 months 33
months and your range of income during
those 33 months well i started at 57 and
ended up at 1 15.
whoa
nice jump in income what do you do for a
living i moved to san diego
what do you do for a living i'm a nurse
okay all right and so you were a nurse
before but you just got a better gig yes
all right cool very cool good for you so
what was the 80 000 student loans um
mostly um 64 student loans i had a car
debt credit cards and you know normal
you were just kind of normal okay how
old are you i'm 32. 32. all right where
were you living before san diego tampa
what made you go to san diego oh you
became a travel nurse oh you're a travel
nurse oh like i used to i
started as a travel nurse and then i
ended up getting a job there okay good
so how did you get connected to this
ramsay stuff the ramsey way oh well in
2018 i bought a house and this guy came
over to my house to show me that no
appliances because they had just built
it
and
he started talking to me about how great
i was doing financially
and i i just thought to myself like that
is so not true for sure
and so he started talking about ramsay
and i started to listen to the uh show
and then i woke up one day realizing how
bad of a financial situation i was in
and so
i
just thought that my only option was to
travel because my income wasn't enough
to even come close to pay for the debt i
couldn't afford this house the only way
i was in it was because my parents were
living in it and they were paying some
of the mortgage
and so i became a travel nurse and
i got a job in san diego
and i started paying off debt and when
the pandemic hit i was like this is my
opportunity because now i don't have to
pay interest
and so
it kind of sped up the journey and here
we are i'm so excited hey that's
incredible thank you incredible i think
it's always impressive when people just
say hey on their own they're like you
know what i'm gonna i'm gonna do
something different i'm actually going
to change what i've been doing
and i'm gonna look at money completely
differently okay so how does it how does
it feel
well you know
it seems easy because i got a
raise but it was actually really hard
because that was the
biggest factor but also the hardest
factor because like i think that what
helped me the most was getting away from
the people i was hanging out with
because
everybody wanted to spend and travel
because that's what we nurses do
and so
once i left florida and i was pretty
much starting on my own i lost my
support group at the same time and so
then the pandemic hit i was an icu nurse
and it was really stressful i was there
by myself i just wanted to go home
and
and just go back to my family and forget
this pain that stuff
but i met my fiance now and he was so
supportive
all of the outings he had to support
financially
and so um
yeah
that's amazing and still in the middle
of all that the word you used a while
ago was the the covet was an opportunity
it was an opportunity but a challenge at
the same time it was it was they usually
are
those two they usually go together yeah
yes two sides to the same coin yeah yeah
wow it was but i mean that it's
interesting that when you're
scraping and scratch scraping and
grinding and hustling towards a goal
that something comes up you can see it
as an opportunity but otherwise you
wouldn't see it as that one yeah i would
have been like well i can so you sold
the house in florida i take it i did i
sold it even though my parents didn't
agree
yeah so they had to move
they did oh where did they move they
rented an apartment okay because
they survived your transition then they
did they did and that had to be a little
bit of a conflict in the air a little
scary conversation i mean you threw your
parents out that's hard
kind of it's hard i mean it is you it's
a it was a grown-up girl decision i
applaud you for it but a lot of people
would really really really not do that
and they should you should have done
exactly what you did well i thought i
was helping them at the same time
because i felt like once i did this i
they would see that this is possible and
so that was my thought my sister paid
off her her student loans and my
brother's also on the journey oh my gosh
this is what i feel like this is why i
did this yes well you've inspired the
whole family then yes way to go good for
you that's very very cool that's amazing
okay so what would you say to someone in
their early 30s
that's just been living paycheck to
paycheck they may have a great income
but they're like this is just what it is
like there are these student loans are
always gonna be around you're always
gonna have a car payment
what would you say to someone that
thinks
i can't do what mate did no that sounds
so hard i don't think that's possible
well i i think the whole baby step
concept is the trick because like you
have to even because my brother's in the
same situation he just doesn't make as
much of an income as i do but he has his
1 000 uh dollars emergency fund and he
pays however little he can pay and uh
he's actually trying to work on
improving or increasing his income and
so you just do what you can do and then
the rest you know
you just
get by it keep pushing through just keep
pushing for sure yeah and you did it 33
months yes how's it feel to be free
um well what i feel like
the what i earned out of this the uh was
freedom it was
it was the freedom to make choices
because now i can
make choices that i couldn't make before
like i ultimately
want to in the future have my own
business and i feel like i would have
never had even the thought of of having
that opportunity if i would still be in
eighty thousand dollars of loans yeah so
exactly right
exactly right it is choices because
what you do is you give up your choices
that's why the bible says the borrower
is slave
to the lender you surrender your choices
when you're over oh all these people and
the good news is you broke free
well done congratulations
work very very good work hey we got a
copy of baby steps millionaires for you
that is the next chapter in your story
how ordinary people build extraordinary
wealth how you can too we fully expect
you to be a millionaire that's the next
chapter for you thank you and we'll give
you a copy of this in financial peace
university a one-year membership thank
you and you either use that or you can
give it away same thing with the total
money makeover book we're going to give
you so you can use it or give it away
whatever you want to do we're very proud
of you thank you who was your biggest
cheerleaders my siblings were my biggest
cheerleaders because they would always
be like um oh i want to buy this they'll
be like is that on the budget
no but yeah accountability partners too
yeah very good hey you got them you got
the whole family working on it you
shifted the i mean you caused an
earthquake girl it's very very well done
very well done all right may from san
diego 80 000 paid off in 33 months
making 57 to 115. count it down let's
hear a debt-free scream three two one
and they're free
[Music]
[Applause]
pretty incredible
wow
it's awesome fabulously done you know
everyone's stories and situations
they're all different right and they all
have glimpses of these moments that
you're like oh that's just amazing
amazing amazing but even just like you
know i know she's engaged right now but
even just as a single person you're like
i'm gonna do it at least when you're
married and you're on the same team you
have each other to like well and she was
lonely and scared at some point through
that process she said yes i mean that
was a hard road a hard 33 months and so
i mean she can just say to herself like
the pride of i did that like i
i did that and i did the impossible of
what people would say is impossible and
it's incredible yeah incredible changed
everything with that at 33 years old
moved all the way across the country
i mean from tampa to san diego that's
about as far stretch as you can make
right there
and um worked at a hard time medically
during covet as an icu nurse and but
that's
always interesting to me that
you know the old saying einstein said he
said you know
i i have plenty of luck but it usually
comes dressed in overalls and looks like
work clothes
you know and um
you know it's interesting to me that
when you're in the middle of scratching
and clawing for something that she sees
covet as an opportunity
wow
i mean if i was in the medical field at
some points in covet i probably would
not have seen it as an opportunity but
it was it was a valid opportunity a hard
one yeah dark one
thank goodness we got people like her
out there i know such such incredible
stuff this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
rachel cruz ramsey personality is my
co-host today this is the ramsey show we
appreciate you guys being with us our
condolences to the royal family as the
queen has passed
and uh very sad
70 years
13 presidents she entertained
quite a uh well she took the throne so
early in life yeah and quite a lady
obviously amazing yeah i mean the
amazing number of movies books
everything else
about her about the whole process pretty
pretty wild but um
sad sad for uh the british people said
for the world it's a loss it's a loss
so you sent me this silly thing this
morning and i watched it and it's just
like oh my god these people okay so what
is this
okay so
there's a thing called instagram
if you're unaware
and it's my social media of choice i
don't really do twitter i don't really
do facebook i just i do love instagram
so i i look at i look at instagram okay
so i'm in i'm in my stuff so people will
send me clips that are on instagram from
like funny stuff to you know even their
own journeys and i see a lot of it
because i do try to go through it so
this one clip has been sent to me i'm
not kidding probably 10 times from 10
random people all over the world that
are just like can you believe this guy
can you you know this this this and i
kept seeing it come up and so
i had i clicked on i was like oh man
number one it's terrible advice i think
it came originally maybe it was a tick
tock video but it's an instagram reel of
how it's like a tick tock video and
because there's ev everyone's a
financial expert on social media today
right and with investing they all know
what they're gonna do and how to get how
you make money quick and all this stuff
you know you gotta you gotta do all this
stuff so anyway so here's a video it was
a and it's a father-daughter which
you'll see and i just thought well
here's a father-daughter and i don't
want to harp on them i want to harp on
this situation i do i know you do okay
let's let's let's play the play the
instagram reel
this is my daughter maddie
we're at a car dealership right now and
she's about to buy her first car tell me
how you're buying your first car this
morning i went to the bank i got my
first car loan i qualified for
000. at what interest rate 3.5
with the money that i have saved up i
have seven thousand dollars in cash i'm
going to invest that into an airbnb
property and get 14
interest back so that way i can use that
money to pay off my car loans so
basically kind of getting your car for
free wait maddie can you explain that
one more time a little more simply yeah
so it cost me three cents to borrow a
dollar from the bank and then i go and
take that dollar not my dollar and i
give to someone for 14 cents and then so
14 minus 3 11. so i keep the difference
in the middle wait what's that called
arbitrage boom you buy
assets that then cash flow and pay
for your stuff
i mean he's so proud well i mean he's so
slimy there's a few things you need to
take a shower after watching that oh my
gosh
it just drips in arrogance
well there's a lot there's a lot of
things about this number one i really
don't feel like you can get an interest
rate
i don't think you can get a lot she's
how old was she she's 15 she cannot get
a bank loan no so he co-signed which
probably helped get a lower interest
rate and then what i don't understand is
the eleven thousand dollars in an airbnb
property you can't buy an airbnb
property for 11 000 either you could
invest in it with a bunch of partners
into an airbnb property and that's
assuming the airbnb property stays
rented and the local city council
doesn't pass a law against airbnbs in
which case your little butt would be
broke at 15 years old because your
father's a [ __ ]
oh my god
was that unclear no
i was like we're not going to harp on
the people
but speak to the notion though because
that stuff is everywhere that you get
you you borrow this you take that
percentage and that difference and you
go get that asset and then in this and
that and you play this game full
disclosure i had you on stage at 15
years old okay oh what a slimy so full
disclosure nothing so full disclosure
the difference is the advice that we
were giving was not so bad
and we were not as slimy or
condescending i don't think oh my god
it's called arbitrage okay which is
greek for i'm stupid oh my god
oh okay but talk about the that notion
though because that well it's
the set of assumptions the set of
assumptions you have to go through for
all that crap to be true are absolutely
ludicrous okay number one you have never
met a millionaire we studied 10 167 of
them zero of them precisely zero said i
borrowed money on my car
and arbitraged it into being a
millionaire
zero real millionaires do that zero
zero none
i borrowed money on my car and put
eleven thousand dollars into an airbnb
when i was fifteen
with all of my business acumen on
display
because she didn't even know what the
interest rate was go back and watch the
clip again she's well i i i
wa and they had to edit it and what was
it oh three and a half well tell them
again
tell them again darling what you did oh
she don't even know what she did
she really didn't
she was a little parrot
so you know
number one number but the the whole
concept of i'm gonna borrow
on assets listen you duber cars go down
in value yes you can call them an asset
if you want but they're not much of an
asset and if you leverage your car to
get rich you might never get there
this is
because mathematically is that's true
but also the spirit behind it well
mathematically it's
you are not measuring risk
and you're making a set of assumptions
that a 13 year old 15 year old can
borrow money at three and a half percent
they can't you can't contract unless
you're a legal adult and borrowing money
is a contract in any state in the united
states okay that's why a kid can't have
a mutual fund you have to have a
custodial account that's why a kid can't
have a savings account or a checking
account you have to have a parent on
there as a custodian because kids can't
contract they can't buy beer and they
can't borrow money from a car dealer
god
um so now then once you've done all that
though let's just pretend you weren't a
kid and you went and really borrowed
money at three and a half percent here's
the thing you have to follow
factual
causation find people who have actually
done
your theory
find me one
who 15 years later using that type of
system
is a millionaire or greater you can't
find them because they're not there
they're not there okay doesn't work let
me ask you this question
uh because there is again there's this
this thing that is floating around in
the culture there really is though
that's called stupidity yeah i know
let me just present the stupidity and
then you can you can debunk it because
you're really great at that right now
okay
that um you know if you just like want
to kind of be like yeah maybe you can
just like like you can have some some
wealth and you just that that's what
investing does and it's but if you
really want to become like super wealthy
you you you have to you know be in real
you have to do these these things these
jump through hoops and you're and you're
doing math that most people can't grasp
and understand because you're playing
the game i mean this is a perfect
example like the way he's
uh it's called arbitrage the way he's
explaining it makes it feel like oh
there's something i'm missing
and in order to build wealth and to
become rich there's other systems that i
don't know about that can cause me to
become rich
and is there a level of that 30 years
ago when i came on the air
the secrets of the rich
were out there then
everybody got a book it seeks seven
secrets to getting rich
here's the problem
it's not a secret
there's not a magic sauce
there's not a magic sauce
mcdonald's special sauce is basically
thousand island there is no special
sauce okay there's not any that's it i
mean you really you gotta live on less
than you make you have to invest
steadily over a long period of time and
there is no like i learned a new word
and that made me wealthy
if you know maybe compound interest
would be close okay but compound
interest works over time with time and
consistency so maybe that's a new word
for him and he learns that word and
that's a good word but you you know the
the people that say there's a short
they're looking for a shortcut i mean
that's what it is that's what i'm saying
and they're brilliant they're brilliant
they know things because they're on
tick-tock and they know oh god shoot me
um
i just i'm having trouble finding
intelligent life on tick tock we're
going to have to get on tick tock i'm
not on tick tock i don't that's not on
my phone i don't want to i just i can't
i don't want it on my phone but i guess
we're going to have to
we're going to have to put content on
there to just
mess with this
we're putting money out there we're
putting money out there or advice out
there but kill him
what's happening this is the ramsey show
[Music]
dave here we just launched a brand new
audience survey for the ramsay show and
we'd love your feedback you could be
entered to win a 500 visa gift card no
purchase necessary take the survey at
ramseysolutions.com
survey
[Music]
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the pods
moving and storage and studio it's the
ramsey show where debt is dumb cash is
king and the paid off home mortgage has
taken the place of the bmw as the status
symbol of choice we help people build
wealth do work that they actually love
and create real amazing relationships
i'm dave ramsey your host rachel cruz
ramsey personality number one
best-selling author my daughter is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five
five
two two five
so rachel your smiling face is
overlooking times square
digital billboards oh i had no clue
where you're going with that i was like
what is my smiling face doing yes i
someone texted us a picture amazon music
has a a series of digital billboards
across the side of two buildings it's
massive uh in times square there's lots
of huge digital billboards in times
square and uh
we're uh
have uh
working with amazon music to carry this
podcast uh now i think everyone carries
the podcast that possibly carries a
podcast that we know of anyway we
appreciate them carrying it and um they
were nice enough to feature the ramsey
show with a picture of you and dr john
deloney and me
uh and uh you worked too hard to be this
broke and uh lying on there and uh so a
little time square advertisement for the
ramsey show brought to you by the
fighting folks at amazon music and uh
you can also find this show there so
thank you guys for that pretty pretty
cool
it's awesome yeah one of our guys was up
there doing something on the team and
took pictures of the actual our video of
the actual thing turning because
it stays up there like four seconds and
then
literally and then comes back around
every 16 seconds or so yeah like four
different panels they use on them uh but
in that environment it's uh it's pretty
wild
that can see it which is awesome of
people that you know you may not have
reached unless you people hanging out in
times square so it's awesome
i hope we can help that's what we're
here for open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five
raul is with us in phoenix hey raul ah
lee i cannot push the right button today
there we go raul is with us hey raul how
are you
good how are you better than i deserve
what's up
hey thank you for taking my call and
thank you for all of you guys what you
do there inspired me a lot and i'm sure
it inspired so many other listeners too
thank you very nice
quick
quick background i'm a 30 years old i
have a master's and i graduated from the
doctorate degree a couple months ago
moved to phoenix arizona
because i find a job here so my first
question my question is
my compensation for the first is 180k
and then from starting next year would
be ranging between 20 to 50 k
up
bonus on my base salary so way to go
thank you uh we graduated i graduated
from the debt free so me and my wife
worked throughout the school i did go
and paid off 180k of my school and also
paired up paid up for a car 30k so we
are completing that free now wow and was
just wondering
how do i start from here how do i start
investing building valve
to to have the good retirement wow it's
like what's your phd in
uh pharmaceutical sciences
okay good for you what are you doing
we're living
uh
i would be a
project manager in one of the big
companies yeah i thought so research r d
yeah
okay man well i would take out a car
loan and arbitrage which is what i'm
hearing i'm just kidding i'm just
kidding that's from another segment
i'm a failure as a father that's the
first thing i thought
take out a carl and invest in airbnb
that's what i would do
no really though
you guys have done a fantastic job i
mean you really you're definitely one of
the
success stories that
you're because your income even rose not
your lifestyle right you guys did really
well with the income you had to pay off
your debt and to do the right things and
to set you guys up so well because now
you will be able
um yeah to invest greatly so we do
recommend
investing 15 of your income
into retirement and so things like your
401k or 403b
roth ira and keeping that steady
investing for the long term and that's
your 15 and then do you guys have kids
yes we i have two-year-old okay and so
looking at college uh for your
three-year-old and looking ahead and
saying okay we want to save up
uh for their college and with your
income that's going to yeah you'll have
definitely the margin why is your wife
working outside the home sir
no not until not now okay so you'll be
able to match that you'll be able to max
out your 401k i assume they offer a roth
401k in some match correct
they offer 401k up to seven percent
really
um you mean a match up to seven percent
yeah match up to seven percent yes you
can put the max of your 401k in there
22 000. okay and so you put all that in
then you get all the match do it all in
a roth 401k in good growth stock mutual
funds we spread it across four types
growth growth and income aggressive
growth and international fund your kids
college fund
each of you can do back door roths
you're going to make too much money to
do a traditional a regular roth but you
can do what's called a backdoor roth get
with a smartvestor pro
at ramseysolutions.com that's in your
area they'll sit down and teach you how
to start these basic investing things
going and that's your first step to
investing
your next step is get the house paid off
and once that's paid off then you can
decide what the surplus you've got
beyond those things and you will have
surplus because your income is going to
continue to go up you're obviously an
unusually bright guy very smart
and uh um
so
you're going to end up making amazing
amounts of money and always be enjoying
some of it giving some of it and
investing some of it
always enjoy it
give it
and invest it and i would put
percentages on that i just gave you
percentages on minimums to get started
on your investing side but make sure
that your lifestyle is not ridiculously
low if you make 250 000 a year it
doesn't need to be but make sure you're
not consuming it all with your lifestyle
and make sure you're not investing
everything and having no generosity in
your family
so we want to we want to have all three
things functioning the people that we
find that have high quality
happiness
coefficients we find happy
well-balanced mentally healthy people
with good relationships that are wealthy
and there's lots of them there's they're
everywhere but the people that we find
that fall in those categories are always
generous they always have a reasonable
level of enjoyment not over enjoying it
not hedonistic
and they always are steadily investing i
was doing those three categories and you
and i taught that just to teach your own
kids and smart money smart kids you're
first number one yeah no for sure i mean
it's it's the basics of all three and
here's what's fascinating too
you know people really do think if i
could just make more money
everything will be okay right and and
the habits that you have carry on with
you and and speaking of social media and
instagram there's this account that she
does these budgets people submit their
income and their budgets for the month
and she and she shows them on the
account anyways long story short this
couple makes like 3 million a year it's
like 70 80
90 a
a month and they spend it all they have
like twelve hundred dollars left over
it's like four thousand on clothes they
have a full time all this stuff and i'm
like oh my gosh it's just crazy you can
still spend your way into stupidity
regardless of your income so
those three
principles are so important they're so
important to give save and spend
congress has proven that for years
this is the ramsay shock
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
have you ever noticed when you commit to
one change in one area of your life that
you tend to make progress in other areas
we've met thousands of people on their
journey to building wealth who
accomplished other amazing things along
the way like they lost 50 pounds they
found a career that they love their
income went up they overcome stress and
anxiety
and depression what seems impossible
becomes possible when you have a smart
plan
and you turn up the focus and intensity
on your goals that's why we're bringing
the smart conference to dallas texas
saturday october 22nd smart conference
is the one day event where you're going
to hear from the top thought leaders and
authors in every subject
from marriage
yep our friends uh doctor our pastor
craig groeschel and his wife amy will be
with us to uh speak on marriage we'll be
talking about mental health dr john
dolone will be with us doing that we'll
be talking about careers and getting the
job and you love and passion and and in
your work and man ken coleman will be
talking about that uh our newest
personality that's on stage this week
this year is george campbell and man is
he a hot property people are loving
george and everything he's saying he's
gonna be talking about money rachel cruz
to my right will be their best-selling
author talking about money and i'll
close up the day talking about your life
and how we put it all together with a
sense of intentionality and your
spiritual walk yeah
all about god so you're going to love
this it's called the smart conference
it's all day long when you leave you
will be smarter and it's a whole 35
dollars because the vip and platinum are
all sold out so general admission is all
there is again october 22nd in dallas
texas it is the only live event we have
for the fall that has any tickets left
so if you want to come to dallas texas
this is your place right now uh
ramseysolutions.com events to find out
about all of our events especially the
smart conference on october
the 22nd maria is with us maria is in
houston texas hi maria how are you
hi it's a privilege to speak with you
thank you i am debating between selling
my home and refinancing my home i'm on
baby step two i recently got divorced
and so i have to give him a third of the
proceeds of the sale i have spoken to a
real estate agent actually one of your
elp referrals
and also a credit union um
and i have a daughter in high school
she's a senior
so selling my home would mean putting
her through college debt-free
and i do have a place to go to with my
sister she recently widowed so um
i do have a place um and the reason for
refinancing um is because i don't plan
to be with my sister long term
so um if if i go live with my history it
would be
just to save for a new home in the
future
and i don't know if it makes sense to
sell the home when i'm gonna
come back in two five years to to buy a
new home yeah what what do you owe on it
i only owe 15 000. 15 000.
yes yeah and you owe and what what is it
worth
225.
okay so you owe him like 65 or 70 000
bucks huh that's cool right correct and
what do you make
i mean 66 a year
that's gross
how long were you married
um over 20 years but it's it's it's it
was about
you know
it's a good thing because i got divorced
so i understand
but
there's a lot of um
bad memories in this home
um
yes and at the same time i do like the
home at the same time it's a good it's a
good home and
i can see myself staying there um i
could also see myself in a meal in a new
home how old are you
i am 47.
what do you do for a living
i am a legal assistant yeah
okay is the daughter you're you're
talking about maria she your only child
no she's my youngest i actually have
three okay is he responsible for part of
her college too
i have no communication with him and i
highly doubted that he would be able to
um
participate
okay so even if he was supposed to
he
couldn't because he's
correct he would not be able to because
he's worthless
yes
yes
certainly it took me so long to figure
this out
oh i'm sorry honey you've been through
hell
oh bless your heart
here's one here's what i would like you
to do um
man
there's not a bad answer here okay
it's not bad to sell the home moving
with your sister send your kid to
college and come back and buy later
that's not the end of the world
uh if you didn't like the house
i would do that in a heartbeat
you like the house and even me
challenging you with negative memories
you you could see yourself staying there
you only owe 15 000 so at the end of the
story you only owe 85 000 or so or 80
000 to refinance that's a very very low
mortgage
especially when you make 65 000 a year
um and
i'm gonna refinance it and keep it
okay
uh that leaves the daughter in a lurch
for school so we gotta figure that out
okay so
um
number one she's gonna select a school
that's affordable
because she's um her mom's a single mom
who doesn't have a lot of money
okay you're not sitting on two hundred
thousand dollars to send her to school
with so she's gonna select an affordable
in-state school
um
she's going to be working while she's in
school to pay for parts of things
she needs to work on her grades it's
probably too late but she needs to work
on her grades and make sure she takes as
many different things as she can take to
get her grades up to help her get
scholarships and i want her to fill out
500 applications for scholarships
that's not an exaggeration on that not
exactly 500
because all she's got to do is get a few
and she can go to
university hunts university of houston
she can go
uh if i remember uh atm has a you gotta
you got one in in houston right i got
some aggies sitting out here in the
lobby yeah so uh there's a uh
uh
aggies got their they got a branch there
in houston it's probably not called
aggies they're probably called something
else there but um
yeah
so yeah i uh
yeah
we got to get her through school but as
far as the house goes i would keep the
house because you got a very very low
mortgage i don't know rachel what are
you hearing yeah i mean my question is
miranda do you um
you know did you raise all three kids in
this house like is the house for
space wise do you need
do you need all the space like i don't
know what you know what how big the
house is for you and what it is and if
you enjoy it and all that because i mean
like you know another
option would be to sell it
you know obviously you'll have money to
help daughter go through school which is
great live with your sister for a while
while you guys both have been through
something really hard
having someone there you know that's
great and then finding something that is
reasonable for you now that all your
kids are you know you're an empty nester
now
um so that would be the only way to look
at it on the other end of the coin is to
say okay here could be a fresh start in
that sense but
um but i mean it's a great it's a great
asset to have and like and like dave
said your mortgage is going to be low
and
there's a way to go to school debt free
i don't want you to make a
financial a huge financial decision like
a house decision based on four years of
education for your daughter because
she's there because there's options for
her because there's options for her
um but yeah if you were like oh get me
out of this house i don't like it i
don't uh yeah then that's one thing
but if you're kind of okay with it and
what it would do yeah if you had told me
you had a two hundred thousand dollar
mortgage i'd tell you sell it
because you'd be at you'd be rid of the
problem and the and the stress of that
but fifteen thousand dollar mortgage and
you gotta go get 70 or 65 to take him
out
yeah i'm doing that and by the way do
that at your local credit union you
don't need a mortgage mortgage they're
too expensive when it's small like that
just go to your local credit union and
tell them a couple things number one you
want no closing costs
because there's you got a huge
equity so they don't need to charge
closing costs number two you want a
fixed rate
[Music]
you won't do it unless it's a fixed rate
and you won't do it unless it's no
closing costs talk to credit unions
until you find those two things
and um
you can get a better deal that way on
this loan a loan that size a mortgage
company is not a bargain it's a small
loan for them
and they're going to stick you with a
bunch of fees usually so don't do that
wow i'm sorry you've been through this i
hear a lot of pain in this but i'm glad
you're there and i'm glad you're free
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
i say it all the time if you're a
business owner and you don't know your
numbers you don't know your business and
when markets are shifting it's even more
important
you've got to know where you stand so
you make your next move the right move
and you don't have to be in the dark
here over 31 000 businesses including my
team at ramsey know their numbers
because they use netsuite by oracle the
number one cloud financial system
netsuite gives you visibility and
control of your financials planning
budgeting and inventory so you can
manage risk get reliable forecasts and
improve margins having everything in one
place has saved my team hours each week
since we made the switch to netsuite
netsuite is a game changer so head on
over to netsuite.com ramsey to get a
product tour today that's netsuite.com
ramsey
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
rachel cruz ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of ramsey
solutions on the debt-free stage brian
is with us hey brian how are you doing
doing fantastic how about yourself
better than i deserve sir honored to
have you where do you live oklahoma city
all right welcome to nashville very
thank you
very cool so how much debt did you pay
off 47 785 very good how long did that
take uh 24 months in one week all right
love it and your range of income during
that two years so 45 and towards the end
it bumped up to about 60 and that's my
uh what i was netting and uh
between all of my sources of income side
hustles yeah all right cool what do you
do for a living i'm a systems analyst
for a private company that supports the
air force in oklahoma city right now and
uh i also do
some doordash and i started my own small
business uh within the last year what
was the uh most lucrative
best paying side hustle
uh let's see lucrative i would say based
on just not only the financial but also
the
professional development would be the
business that i started with in the last
year i would say with the encouragement
of your platform as well as just kind of
hearing everyone on this very stage it
just gave me the the courage to even try
something like that yeah what was the
business uh so i own just a small it
company kind of catering to one to ten
seats so just residential
uh small businesses just doing
consulting and kind of your general
computer repair and stuff like that
that's awesome if you work from home and
you discovered that i t department is no
longer there for you
enter brian
here is brian yeah good that's a great
idea man i love it good for you that's
fun very very cool okay what kind of
debt was the 48 000 wow um
sorry it's very exciting to be here
thank you again for having me
so a lot of it was credit card i played
the zero percent apr juggling game uh
you know i i thought it was a genius
with money even though i knew absolutely
nothing
i also uh
a little bit of student loans uh so
maybe about five to 10k tied to a couple
of semesters and then uh
embarrassing to admit but it's an honest
part of my story i was on social
security disability for a short period
of time and had uh some overpayment that
needed to be paid back so that was taken
care of and i also in my early 20s got
sued for not having the right insurance
coverage and
that was a fun mess that i decided uh in
good faith to clean up while going
through this whole program and that was
basically the amount of debt that i had
two years ago i've been in debt pretty
much my whole life so thank you again
you guys well thank you you did it i'm
proud of you how's it feel to be free
fantastic uh you know looking back to
some of your videos uh talking about the
leverage that people do and don't have
over us when we're in that type of
predicament not
being in that position anymore is really
liberating to say the least
that we hear that all the time and it is
amazing when you're like okay oh it's
just a car payment it's no big deal
and toyota owns a part of your life
month after month after month i mean
there is something just to be said
whether it's mastercard your student
loan whatever just to be completely free
so what happened then
24 months ago that you were like okay
so
friend my best friend who i've known for
i would say forever it's been about 10
12 13 years uh she's like a sister her
family is my family essentially and
she's here in the studio
with us her name is laurie she just kept
gently bumping my head with the total
money makeover and she's always been the
most
uh financially responsible person that i
kind of knew of that was close to me
gently hit you in the head with a book
metaphorically uh but it it had the same
effect so i i just uh i was tired i've
heard this term before i was tired of
having my pants down you know whether it
was dating outside of my social class or
it was uh get getting exposed to job
opportunities that were being
pushed down because of all the pressure
that was on my back because of not
taking care of my own financial
responsibility it was i just got tired
of all the doors being closed and so i i
read the book i uh basically started
looking through the class literature i
was too cheap to pay for every dollar so
i actually realized that
there wasn't a prerequisite to become a
coordinator so i just dove in and taught
it to myself and started spinning up
some of those classes
and um i just i went crazy i was
listening to your podcast every day
doing like amazon shopping and a variety
of other things
and every single day i was making money
and maybe three to six months into
living actually in massachusetts i was
living about 25 miles northeast of
boston uh kovid the last individual that
was on the stage
it was very inspiring
i could relate to kovid being an
opportunity when all that stuff closed
down and i was working remotely i
thought to myself you know what i love
massachusetts but i'm not an owner i
don't own anything here uh find some
population density in a place i've never
been before that cost a lot less and i'm
i did a blind move to oklahoma city and
i wouldn't have been able to do that
without you guys wow so it just it cut
into that last little category that was
becoming just a thorn in my side
and um
you know i've been i've been there ever
since and it's just it it's it's been
life-changing well praise god man you're
amazing you've had a lot of life change
moving and everything i mean that's a
lot there's a lot of transformation
going on with you you're a neat guy well
done sir well done very very proud of
you very proud of you good work
wow okay you've been a coordinator
um albeit for selfish reasons but it's
still a good coordinator that's how the
best ones start by the way and uh y'all
can go through for free yeah that's it
that's a good i get a lot of good ones
that way but i thank you for leading the
classes you've been a coordinator you've
been through it yourself you've been
gently bumped in the head with a book um
and you paid off 48 000 in 24 months in
one week you are by far an expert on
getting out of debt in america today
what is the secret to getting out of
that so it's not going to sound gentle
but there are two things uh stop
complaining and basically just
gain some clarity on who you're spending
time with responsibility
can and definitely will be somewhat
contagious and not that other people are
responsible for your decisions but
basically just make sure that your goals
align with the people that you surround
yourself by those would be my biggest
recommendations and don't get me wrong i
complain every single day so i'm in no
place to judge other individuals that do
it but it does slow down the process of
just opening that door making a few
extra bucks and just pushing forward
yeah wow
well good for you man that's a great
piece of advice though the attitude
through it right because the budget's a
great tool like there's a bunch of stuff
that adds up in this process that helps
people
become debt free yeah but that
overarching thread of just your attitude
of how you're looking at it can either
make the process somewhat bearable if
like we're going to do this or the whole
time it's just like i can't believe i
can't believe it and your whole life
then becomes that and so i i love that
that it's your attitude of saying hey
yeah it sucks and yeah i may complain
every now and then because it's not fun
but what i tell myself and the thoughts
that i have really do change your
actions so
that's amazing i love that it's your
perspective discipline for discipline's
sake silly
but discipline to get to a greater good
it gives you the right perspective the
right attitude so what are you gonna do
now brian now that you're debt-free you
have no payments
let's see i mean
i have about five to ten uh years to
make my first million aside from that i
don't really have any plans yeah it's
awesome sounds like a good one i'll go
with that one
good work hey we got a copy of baby
steps millionaires for you to help you
do that how ordinary people build
extraordinary wealth how you can too
it's my latest number one
another membership to financial peace
university uh maybe you can find someone
who's too cheap or unable to buy it and
you can give it away to somebody that
needs some help and we'll give you a
copy of total money makeover so you can
bump someone in the head with it that'll
be great and i'm honored by that thank
you lori well done well played it's good
to have friends like you yeah good stuff
man that's very very good proud of you
brother very proud of you excellent job
brian from oklahoma city 48 000 paid off
in 24 months in one week making 45 to
60. count it down let's hear a debt free
scream three
two
one
i'm debt free
[Applause]
that's how it's done boys and girls
so good
last two dead free screams singles
that's right
same with him yeah singles
i love singles i like it
i like it i like it because it takes
that extra level of perseverance when
you're like okay i mean yeah when you
when you haven't got anybody to gripe at
you but you don't have anybody gripe at
it that's right i mean it's you know i
mean it's it's harder so very cool very
well done it takes an extra level of
backbone to do it when you're single i
think but people do it all the time and
we see people from everywhere all across
america
every shape size and background baby boy
baby boy baby girl this is how it works
thanks for being with us america this is
the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
rachel cruz number one best-selling
author ramsey personality my daughter is
my co-host today
your calls at
825-5225 michelle is in baltimore hi
michelle how are you
hi i'm fine good how can we help all
right actually i'm not fine i'm debt
free but i'm stressed out
i'm struggling i have my emergency fund
and so i thought i was going to be
excited and feel all this peace instead
of stress
i'm struggling to save fifteen percent
of my income
in in a roth um retirement fund plus
ties and try to stay for anything a
house a car anything else
so i must be doing something wrong
through doing a written budget the same
thing i did to get out of debt and save
money working a part-time job also
you mean you said save for a house or a
car is that what you're saying
yes anything by the time i try to do 15
of my income
tough ties
you know it's not much left over unless
i'm
for the rest of my life i just work in a
part-time job
what's your household income
and i thought it was a lot 92.
92 is that what you said michelle
yeah 92 000. yeah and i did the smart
investor pro and i was all excited and
we did the 15
and when my check came i was like whoa
i can't pay the bills
what is your uh
you got you got a rental or a house
payment are you a renter
i'm doing renting fifteen hundred
dollars in rent okay which is cheap for
this area and i hope it stays that way
you getting a big tax refund every year
unfortunately not um are you paying a
lot for health care insurance
i am
what are you paying
um i'm paying about um
if this went up to about three per check
i also have two kids three what per
check three i'm sorry 300 uh you get
paid how often
every two weeks
600 a month is not bad okay all right
okay so you got eighteen thousand and
uh twelve thousand
and that's thirty thousand
and your taxes would be
fifteen probably
that's 45 at least 45 i don't know where
all your money is going because your
rent is eighteen thousand dollars a year
fifteen percent is twelve thousand
dollars a year four thirteen thousand
dollars a year of your ninety 000.
um
your health insurance
company
yeah 1500 is 18 000 a year
right bg minus electricity 115 yeah
internet 75 time would be 768. yeah food
um down to 300 trying to do that uh cell
phone gas
and that yeah and so trying you know and
that's
and when i did the 15
and if i want to save to eventually buy
a house
i'm not able to
make that happen
15 would be just a little over a
thousand dollars a month
right so it's about five of each check
five something out of each check yeah
five three i think it was 5 30 out of
these checks yeah that sounds right
and my cards are 2 2012.
um i'm cutting my own hair
yeah i mean you're you're you're
throwing about about a lot of emotional
triggers but i'm still not finding all
your money i'm cutting my own hair i
don't eat i all this stuff but um all of
that has to do with your emotional state
it doesn't have to do with the actual
math
and the actual math i still got room in
i still got about 3 000 bucks a month
laying around there miscellaneous i mean
you're using up some of it with basic
stuff i get that um and i i might have
to sit down to the whole budget to see
it but i
um right now i don't there's i keep what
i usually do in these calls when i'm
talking to someone in this situation
michelle is i'm looking for
the offender
in mathematically what is what is
offending
what's sucking up all the money so that
michelle has none and has worry instead
and i'm looking for that offender it's
not your rent it's not out of control
it's not the 15 percent that's not out
of control it's not the uh you know your
water your gas that's just not out of
control you're not overspending on food
that's not out of control i don't hear
anything in here that's like way over
the top uh your health care is not at
cost is not out of control um you know
it's 600 bucks a month
um
you know in today's world that's cheap
with two kids uh maybe it's daycare
maybe your daycare is super expensive
um or maybe you got the kids in a
private school i don't know uh but what
i'm looking for here are i just take 92
000 and i take taxes out and i take 1500
a month out for rent which is 18 000 and
i take 13 000 bucks out for the 15 and
when i started taking that out i still
got a lot of money left as i go along
this this line here and i'm having
trouble finding it
so um you know i tell you let's do this
um
it sounds like that uh
uh
you're not gonna fix
this situation with cutting your own
hair that's not what this is about or
not eating
you know cutting your food budget down
that's not what this is about you need
to get to the root of where all this
where your money's going and get com
more comfortable with the balance of
that now you're not going to save five
thousand bucks a month on towards a
house when you're putting in this
situation you don't have that kind of
income
um
and so you you may put your 401 k on you
may put your retirement on hold for a
little while while you save for a house
or save for a car if you're getting a
pinch on something that's stuff we teach
called baby step 3b
uh but i i'm gonna put you on hold and
we're gonna give you a free
coaching session with one of our
financial coaches who can get into this
in more detail than we can on a radio
call because this is not the format for
me to
go any deeper into the numbers yeah and
i would want to know too michelle you
know you're on baby step four five and
six which is amazing um but where that
extra margin of not having the debt not
focusing all your time on saving up an
emergency fund so where was all where
all that money that was going to those
things where is it now how much were you
putting away a month towards your
emergency fund through baby step three
where is that going and and i think it's
a hard realization too
um
you know that doesn't necessarily help
you michelle but i can empathize with
just the fact that like life's expensive
and once you do it all right once you
give
once you pay your rent once you're
funding retirement i mean your tithe is
nine thousand bucks
it takes
it does chip away on what feels like
okay 92 grand like that that's a great
income and then the reality of life
though i mean there is a reality that
when you do all of this stuff it it it
does
dwindle i mean it does dwindle and so um
i would kind of figure out yeah what the
what the big things in your life are
which we didn't get to on this call but
whether it is
a child care situation or i don't know
what it may be
um
but to kind of find that so that you're
not stressed or that you can like really
see the extra money and get some kind of
traction but um but i agree that yeah
that that is a defeating feeling when
you feel like you should be
feeling good you're not
um
[Music]
yeah raising two kids in baltimore
as a single mom on 92 is still no picnic
even when you're debt-free
that's right it's fair to say that yeah
it's not it's not like it's gonna be a
hot knife through butter and like
suddenly you're gonna feel like you hit
the lotto or something and you got 20
million bucks because you don't
um that that's fair but is it so
defeating that you can't go win still
over time no it's not yeah it's not
and um
you know and i don't hear a single thing
in here that so far that i would jump on
and go oh you got to stop that that's
that's what there it is that's the thing
and that's what i'm always looking for
because there's usually something like
that in there yeah there's still a you
know there's a big old car payment and
you got rid of all your debt or there's
something like that there's something in
there that's
that's hundreds of dollars causing a log
jam and it's um it's not here it may
just be that
you know inflation is catching up
and is affecting her because she didn't
have a lot of margin to start with
and uh but it probably it may be too
that you have to put your baby step four
on hold to save towards the house if for
two or three years we talk about doing
that in baby step 3b and we're not mad
at you for doing that um i don't want
you to use this as an excuse to never
save for retirement yeah i can't afford
it yes you can you can afford it it
means you can't afford something else
but you can afford it so um
and i'll bet you you had more than a
thousand dollars a month in payments on
the other stuff before you got rid of
them that's what i want to kind of
figure out where was that money going
where is that going now i bet you did i
bet you did and somehow you figured out
a way to make that and to get rid of
that debt yeah yeah so it's a it's doing
great it's a really good it's a journey
it's a journey it's a really good
question and thanks for joining us hang
on we'll help you with a coach okay this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
dave here we just launched a brand new
audience survey for the ramsay show and
we'd love your feedback you could be
entered to win a 500 visa gift card no
purchase necessary take the survey at
ramseysolutions.com
survey
[Music]
bye
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the potts
moving and storage studio it's the
ramsey show where debt is dumb cash is
king and the paid off home mortgage has
taken the place of the bmw as the status
symbol of choice we help people build
wealth new work that they love and
create actual amazing relationships
rachel cruz ramsey personality number
one best-selling author my daughter is
my co-host today open phone is a triple
eight eight two five five two two five
jennifer starts off this hour in
philadelphia hi jennifer how are you
hi dave hi rachel how are you guys great
how can we help
so my husband and i are on baby step two
and
i'm looking at the seven baby steps and
i had a question about baby step five
not to jump ahead but
um my daughter is 27
and i just found out about you in my
defense in march
so she has student debt about seventy
thousand dollars
um because mom didn't pay for it i had a
different perspective prior to listening
to you
so my question is when i get to baby
step five should i help her pay off her
student debt or is it now her
responsibility because mom didn't help
sooner
although i did give her 15 000 with my
husband's help on her room and rent
um
i don't know if i've ever had this
question before
it's an interesting perspective though
because usually it's the
27 year old that calls us and says i'm
debt-free i paid off 70 000 student loan
debt uh because technically you know
it's her debt that she took on yes was
the guidance from you
unknowing
helping her into that situation of debt
yes
um
but to a point i'm like i
it it was her that did it though do you
know what i'm saying it was her that got
the education
off on some of those loans with her
because again i had a totally different
perspective
totally are you are you a co-signer now
is that what you're saying
no she's so responsible she refinanced
how you didn't sign off on anything then
well i did but then she refinanced
oh okay
okay so she has 70 000 student loan debt
what is her degree in
she is a nurse she has bsn okay
and why is she single
she is what does she make
between 80 and 85 000 more than mom
okay
you are a sweet lady
you do not owe this money you do not owe
this money
okay your daughter is um
legally morally and capable
of handling this
okay and mathematically capable of
handling it
it's not you you didn't harm her
um you didn't set out with malice to you
didn't benefit from this in some way
this is not money you stole that was
your daughter's from her trust fund this
is not anything like that she simply
went and stood i mean
if um no you're not i i don't you're not
liable and i i want to set you free and
i got a feeling your daughter doesn't
think you're liable
she doesn't she she actually is okay
because her and i have talked about
she's okay with paying it
but i'm like you know i understand that
you feel guilty
for her yeah you're a sweet lady you're
very sweet
thank you and yeah it's just um you have
a good heart and a a strong conscience
and
that's a good thing um
so if you were
uh worth 20 million dollars or 5 million
or something like that and you want to
take 70 000 and write a check pay it off
that would be fine
uh you're not in that situation and if
you did do that it would not be a baby
step five thing anyway it would be a
baby step seven thing
right it would just be i'm helping my
kids because i'm rich
[Laughter]
i'm not there again well you'll be there
you'll be there someday but she'll be
out of debt by the time you're there
so um
yeah and she's she's okay you have not
harmed her for life she's not
permanently scarred this isn't she's not
under some kind of burden she can't
recover from you have not destroyed her
um she's fine she's going to get her
debts paid off and uh i'll tell you what
let's let's let her go through financial
peace university and rachel and i will
pay for it we'll give it to you okay oh
wow that um that would be fantastic yeah
sign her up and send her through that
and um
and just tell her that we're cheering
for yeah because jennifer too we when we
talk to families on the baby steps you
know we
we tell them that like hey if you're on
baby step you know five and
your kid is a senior in high school and
you don't have the money college is not
an entitlement and you are not a bad
parent for not helping fund college
there are ways to go to school
debt-free now i understand that this is
the back end of that conversation of you
incur maybe encouraging the student
loans or telling it's not a big deal all
that so i get that guilt uh but you have
to let that go jennifer i mean i think
that you know pete we've had two calls
on the stage with people that had
student loans and they a nurse literally
in the first segment and she worked her
way out so it is mathematically possible
for your daughter
paid off 80 80 thousand dollars when she
was 33 years old yeah yeah very very
close that's very close
so it's doable but i think again your
heart behind it jennifer is awesome and
i think that there could be a great goal
because you're you wanting to
um
you know
quote-unquote fix that mistake that
maybe you helped guide her in uh maybe
you make a goal for yourself and baby
step seven i wanna take my daughter and
we're gonna go on a great vacation and i
wanna pay for it and enjoy it and make
that a goal for baby step seven you know
you can still do stuff to bless her and
to love her but you are not obligated
nor are you in a position yet to feel
like you have to cover that 70 000
that's in her name exactly
and uh but it is nice to talk to people
with honor
and that have a conscience and that feel
the responsibility as a parent too right
because it's that feeling of like man i
messed that one up and i want to go and
repair that so that's a very honest
honest feeling but
the position you're in jennifer i would
just i would keep going along and she's
going to be okay yep
open phones at
825-5225
thank you for joining us america we're
so glad you're here we appreciate you
being with us the evils of the student
loan debacle continue
and uh the
documentary borrowed future is heating
up again
its popularity is um randomly
organically rising with the uh biden
administration's token offer to prop up
the midterms
with a uh with a student loan
sorta kinda maybe probably not
forgiveness
so i heard an interesting another stat
on this today all right give it to me so
um
my friend steven mansfield who hates
student loans as much as i do and spends
a lot of time in washington coaching and
working with
legislators senators congressmen from
both sides of the aisle
and uh his podcast i was listening to it
today that came out just a couple of
weeks ago
he made an interesting
observation
he says that they have absolutely no
intention of forgiving the student loans
it's a complete political move and he
never does this because he's always
level-headed academic type right
and he said the reason we know this is
is that
zero work has been done at the
administrative level
in the department of education on any of
the websites at studentaid.gov
none of them knew this was coming
you got 30 million people you've got to
serve with this program and you've done
absolutely
zero
preparation on the technical or the uh
or the staffing that's going to be
required the number of people and it's
all got to hit by the end of the year
and they've done
zero
translation they're not really going to
do it
that was an interesting prediction it
was all political he says just to prop
up the midterms this is the ramsey show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
rachel cruz ramsey personality number
one best-selling author my daughter is
my co-host today we have created the
best way to do your daily goal setting
and motivation
it is a modification of a product that
we do with christy wright that was
vastly popular and rachel's doing the
unboxing as we speak since i just
learned that unboxing is a thing oh yeah
apparently opening a box on instagram as
well
wow look at this and so the ramsey goal
planner is here uh at least the first
copy uh we will start taking orders this
week and it will be with you for 2023
that will actually ship them in october
it is larger in format and thus thinner
because we had people ask us to not make
it so chunky the other one was more like
a brick right
uh i guess so i don't really remember
remember it was smaller and thicker yeah
yeah but this has got the uh uh you know
a day a month at a glance and then it's
got daily goals personal and uh somebody
wrote in it i don't know whose it is but
yeah i saw mom's birthday i was like oh
no
but in the beginning of each uh at the
beginning of each there's a uh an
article by rachel cruz dr john deloney
or george campbell and they'll challenge
you to work on your financial your
relational your spiritual goals all
through the year and set your goals and
get things going it begins in uh
it's a beautiful beautiful the design is
gorgeous the designs are good the it's
actually very practical very usable for
your calendar and for tracking your
spiritual goals your financial goals
everything else you can walk all the way
through this and uh man i got to tell
you this thing has been very very
popular we've sold out of them every
year and every year we've tweaked them
and iterated i guess is a better word
and made them better so it's pretty cool
uh they're 49.99 and they're available
for pre-sale now they will ship out in
october the ramsey goal planner good job
rachel well i love it because
you get the month at a glance
that you're able and then
a week and then a week on two years yeah
and then some teaching uh whether it's
on spirituality
relational financial and then you got
your per week so a week at a glance so
it's
yeah there's not tons of stuff i mean
it's good teaching and everything but
yet it's practical because for me when i
look at my calendar i'm like i just need
simple like if i'm getting this this is
this is what i need so yeah it's a mix
of everything to the point you want on a
planner and that's what it is so it's
awesome and it's beautiful there's like
gold yeah four wheels good
it's a good design you see that should
work
shiny shiny shine shine connor is on the
debt-free stage in the lobby of ramsey
solutions with a question hey connor
what's up hey how are you today great
man how can we help um
i work for a family-owned business my
family's been in business for 33 years
my dad is about ready to retire next
year
and that would put
my wife and i
in the in the position of taking over
the company
i guess my question for you is um
what steps should i take to prepare for
that transition and and what steps have
the two of you taken to prepare for that
eventual transition here at ramsay yeah
it's a great question and so you're in
the business currently currently yeah
how many team members are with you guys
about 30 full-time okay what do y'all do
what's the business catering okay
awesome that's so great does the team
see this coming yes okay so they know
that's good i was going to say number
one it's just communication do they
think you can do it or they think you're
incompetent they think they can do it
good it's important connor you can't do
anything i didn't say i didn't ask him
if he could do it if he was confident i
just asked if they thought he i know i
know i know that's a different thing
that's true that's true
that's true
um i mean yeah dave could probably speak
to more of the
logistical
financial legal i don't know all of all
of that but i think just from a from a
team perspective uh i would if i were
you because it's gonna be here in the
next what 12 months
so i would start leading more and more
and more and having him the slower the
transition out
the easier it is when it's just whiplash
you know even if everyone knows it's
happening and it's just like day one
here you are conor and he's gone it's
just so quick
if there's a gradual transition you guys
can do with responsibility and leading
the team the team seeing you slowly
month after month being more and more
visible
more and more in it taking more and more
responsibility leading more and more
so that way when a year happens in a
year when that transition happens it
feels like oh yeah connor's basically
doing it anyways and it's just it's it's
an easier transition on everyone when
it's gradual versus
really fast and the key customers as
well
they need to know oh that's true too
your key accounts that you guys if you
guys have consistent accounts you and
your dad need to be hanging out with
them together
and then your dad doesn't need to go you
need to go okay and that kind of stuff
back and forth so that they they kind of
have that oh no big deal because this is
why it's kind of been all year you know
and it didn't kill us when you know and
so uh you know in a sense you're
watching that here okay we went from the
dave ramsey show to the ramsey show
about a year and a half ago and uh we
went to co-hosts on the air about two
and a half years ago and that's been
part of a decade-long plan to gradually
even transfer the brand so that you
folks our listeners begin to trust these
guys because they're trustworthy
when i'm not here two of the ramsey
personalities are sitting here and you
all some of you like it better which is
fine that's good because there's someday
someday i'm not going to be here you
know i'm the oldest one of the bunch so
okay let me ask this question between
you and your dad is he did he start this
business
yes okay so we got the gen one how's he
doing for tournaments i know i was like
emotionally there is something when you
when he he's built this thing like he
has grinded he's put his his
kid off to college i mean it's a they
there's a lot of deep ownership because
they they're the ones that sacrificed
right we had the benefit of 2nd gen gen
2
coming in and helping alongside and
hopefully growing it even further
but
there's a gen one um
holding on emotionally that is very real
which i i would totally understand so
how do you feel like he will do
in a year when the transition occurs or
even in the next 12 months as you guys
start to transition will he let go of
the reigns do you think i think so it's
um unfortunately we're in a position
where it's um
where he he needs to retire it's a
health concern that's that's arisen so
um
it's that's that's the process there
yeah
he's not got a choice right yeah because
what's what she's talking about what
happens is gen 1 turning over to gen 2
as we've studied family business
transitions and we've studied a bunch of
them
is the most difficult one emotionally
uh it's actually the easiest one in some
other ways but because gen one the
founder is always a hard head
because that's what enables you to pull
it off right you have to fight through
the briars and the bushes and beat off
the lizards and everything else to kill
the dinosaurs whatever it is you got to
do to to get it done right you got to
get her done
and so then when you get ready to turn
that over uh and and i and i did it as
an act of intentionality i started
working on it uh 14 years ago we started
the first stages of our very very very
gradual succession plan that will
probably has another decade left in it
give or take um and so uh uh but the
first time
i planned to be less important and then
i was it was kind of disturbing
it was a little emotionally shocking and
i did it on purpose and i still went oh
i don't know if i like this okay so how
can jen how can a rachel and a connor a
gen 2 help gen one
i'm not asking selfishly i'm really
asking for you conor how can he
best love his dad in this coming year be
outrageously competent
he's so good that he knows he's not
screwed up by handing it to you
and it makes it easier to hand it
it's like if you're teaching a teenager
to drive how can you let them leave the
car leave the house in a you know thirty
thousand dollar automobile i mean it's a
good car
you're not worried about the kid they're
gonna kill the car right and so
you know but how do you let them do that
well you've ridden with them so much
that there you've watched them drive and
they're competent you've been able to
mentor them you've been able to talk to
them about you know you missed your
blinker and no you can't look at your
dad gum phone while you're driving and
you know you've had these conversations
and you've mentored and mentored and
mentored and mentored and they've proven
themselves competent so that when the
brake lights are tapped as they leave
the driveway
first time at 16 or 17 years old and
drive away you don't pass out the floor
with anxiety you go they're going to be
okay
and your dad's the same way you prove
you can drive the car
and then when you go when you drive off
in the car he's not going to be worried
about you or the car
and then here's another fascinating
thing connor which you know the stats
because studying business i don't have
it in my head family business but
there's a small percentage of success
from gen 1 to gen 2 and even less from
gen 2 to gen 3. but the ones that do
succeed
there was like attributes about those
family businesses that you were like
i had a higher calling for one thing you
have to have a sense of calling on this
it can't be just a job
and uh it's you know it's bigger than
just me it's bigger than just dad it's
just it's even bigger than the company
we've got a big higher calling and we're
serving these people with our catering
business to help accomplish what they
need and we're here to help them right
like you find that thing in this sense
of nobility that's big yep since the
nobility in business and there is a
sense of nobility in business but you
gotta the people that have that have a
higher chance of turning it over well
[Music]
[Music]
rachel cruz ramsey personalities my
co-host today in the lobby of ramsey
solutions on the debt-free stage jacob
and jenna are with us hey guys how are
you good how are you doing better than
most dave good good good to have you
guys where do you live
uh we're we live in indianapolis oh cool
welcome to nashville and how much debt
have you guys paid off uh we paid off
and fifty 106
dollars and ninety one cents in total
way to go how long did this take uh 25
and a half months wow good for you and
your range of income during that two
years uh we started in the first year 81
000 and then finished the second year at
126 000. wow nice job good work so what
do you do for a living um i'm an
athletic trainer in an outpatient
setting
and i work as a manager in a warehouse
okay very good so what why did your
income go up so much uh
i got a couple promotions at work there
you go that's good congratulations just
in time
well done well done what kind of debt
was the 106 000 100 student loans whoa
gorilla navi and sally maddie yes
gave the old woman her eviction notice
yes what are your degrees in um i have a
bachelor's in athletic training and i
graduated in chemical engineering all
right very good
very cool so how long are you all great
i'm sorry smart degrees
yes both of them are smart so
uh how long y'all been married a little
over two years okay so about the time
you get married you say game on we're
cleaning this up how did all this go
down how this conversation happened and
this connection to the ramsey way yeah
so it really started my freshman year
college when the debt started
accumulating really she only had 3 500.
i had the rest so sorry married into it
yeah and uh 103 000 you thought he was
worth that
yeah think so
she's stuck with me since the eighth
grade so i mean we're gonna be yeah
we're eighth grade sweethearts yeah you
kind of knew what you were getting into
that yeah i did i'll give a shout out to
my freshman roommate logan urbanski who
introduced myself to your principles but
i didn't really listen to them obviously
i was a failed student there but we got
married in june of 2020 okovid's wedding
oh wow we moved up to indianapolis she
started working i still had a class left
for my degree
i wasn't working and she said hey we're
going to be really doing this get your
butt to work please
and let's do this
i followed ken coleman's principles i
was working in a warehouse as an
associate and then graduated with an
engineering degree but they had a
management role for new hires for
college and got there and got a couple
promotions wow just like that boom boom
so
ken coleman helped here yeah he did okay
so your newlyweds
start this journey where most people you
know will get married and oh yeah they
go and get new cars and they buy a house
and they're taking great vacation
they're just living their newlywed life
but you guys are like no we're gonna pay
off six figures of student loan debt
okay so what was the hardest part of
that and what was the part that would
maybe maybe is the glimmer of hope for
newlyweds out there they're like no i
would do it now versus later
um well you know we were making more
money than we've ever made in our entire
lives so i guess that made it a little
bit easier yeah but communication was
definitely key for us
going into it i'm definitely the free
spirit he's the nerd he's got all the
numbers
so just two different minds kind of
coming together
and just i don't know communication has
been i feel like the biggest thing yeah
for me the hardest part was the emotion
tied to it once we became married and it
was like sent down putting all the
numbers together it finally connected
emotionally with me and spiritually with
ourselves and then we were just game on
at that point
okay so
your roommate introduced you to your
freshman year but you said nah
so how did you connect back up to us at
this proper moment after marriage and go
okay i remember that crazy guy ramsey
here what was the deal i mean how'd you
reconnect yeah so i mean i never really
left ramsey i wouldn't listen to the
podcast and everything and so as a newly
married couple we didn't really have
financial habits so we just stuck with
the plan before we could make any bad
habits we started a plan yeah we started
we also did financial peace university
through our church um online which
definitely helped me with the process
yeah you you got to catch up on what he
had been learning exactly
good very good
very good cool all right so this is
pretty intense
i mean you guys got after it for two
years you've been on beans and rice
there's not a lot of room in this budget
no
who made fun of you
some a little bit from all of our
families a little bit but oh yeah it was
all good harassing right
i thought they thought you'd lost your
mind and joined a call yeah and what was
it what did they think that y'all were
like what what were what would be the
jabs is it like oh you're not going out
to eat guys enjoy life y'all are too
serious like what was the
yeah it was little stuff like that i
remember sitting around the campfire and
his brother-in-law you guys always talk
about your brother-in-law
talking about something about credit
cards and going overseas and i was like
gosh dang it jacob what are we doing
[Laughter]
we're sticking to the plan
we're not following him
that's awesome we love them we love all
our family they've been really
supportive throughout all of this
even though they give us a couple of
jabs here and there yeah for sure that's
kind of like motivation though oh yeah
he's like yeah watch this watch my dust
yeah i like it well done y'all okay what
do you tell people the key to getting
out of that is
um i would just say discipline um
knowing your why in all of it like what
was your why
i feel like um you know being able to
build wealth and leave a legacy for our
family going forward
like whenever we have kids and be able
to live and give like nobody else
and be able to
have it be god's glory and i feel like
that's my big motivation with all of it
and
just staying committed like i said
having communication with each other is
really key in marriage yeah
i kind of have two thought processes
first any high school age students that
are forced to listen by their parents
are willingly
listening right now please know that
student loans are not free money they do
cost you interest time and stress and
stuff so two years of your life two
years of our lives please just avoid it
and get and not have it in your life and
secondly uh just like i think at the
previous debt free screamer said that
just believe that there is another
option out there of living and that you
can do it but please commit yourself to
it
it's good that's so good well you guys
you did it so how does it feel how does
it feel to finally have no student loan
debt it feels good to see the bank
account start growing a little bit yeah
with the emergency fund yeah be able to
keep that money the first shirt for sure
she says she's more motivated to work
now since we get to keep it
i get that
i don't argue that a bit it's like oh
wait that's mine yeah i get to spend it
in joy yeah yeah that's awesome you guys
congratulations very very proud of you
good work good work hey we got another
copy or another membership to financial
peace university give it to your
brother-in-law yeah
i know a guy that needs that
and baby steps millionaires for you guys
this is the next chapter in your story
like you said you can go on and build
wealth and live like no one else and
give like no one else uh this is our
latest number one around here
and of course a total money makeover
book and you can use that to bonk
somebody on the head with as someone
said earlier it's not a bad thing to use
so uh help somebody get started on the
whole process and everything that you've
learned so we're very very proud of you
you're an impressive young couple well
done thank you thanks good work good
work good work jacob and jenna don't you
wish you had started your marriage this
way out there in america yes
106 000 paid off in 25 and a half months
the first two years of marriage making
81-126
count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream
three two one
[Music]
[Applause]
that is how it's done ladies and
gentlemen
wow
you know when i uh first started
teaching this stuff 30 years ago that's
the thing that always came up i wish i'd
learned this when i was young i wish i'd
learned this when i was young and it is
really beautiful to see a couple in
their 20s in the first two years of
marriage come in here and do this and
the 19 year old on youtube that's
watching and doing this stuff and
that's just man there's so
many dollars involved where that's going
to take someone
how
you've got all those decades in front of
you to go do amazing things with money
it can be done at any age that's right
and but man oh man when you do it at
this age you got a whoo
oh the compound i mean we were talking
about compound interest in another
segment but i'm like it's true the
earlier you start and man when they're
able to just put money away they're
gonna be able to give like crazy yep
because they're gonna have the income
they're going to invest
this early on in life which is
incredible buy a home pay i mean all of
it it's just yeah you get a jump start
so and it was them that decided it
that's the thing too is you wake up one
day and say we have six figures of
student loan debt
we're to take care of this it's a hockey
stick life up and to the right baby this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
our scripture of the day first
corinthians 16 13-14 be on your guard
stand firm in the faith be courageous be
strong
do everything in love
queen elizabeth ii
passed
our condolences rest in peace to the
royal family
oh my goodness
what a lady
she said it has always been easy to hate
and destroy
to build and to cherish is much more
difficult
very true our question of the day comes
from blinds.com find out for yourself
why blinds.com is the number one online
retailer of custom window coverings with
free samples free shipping and new
promos they run all the time you'll save
even more use the promo code ramsey to
get the best possible deal today's
question comes from cindy in california
if you donate to charities like animal
rescues local fire police and rescue
departments pro-life pregnancy centers
neighborhood schools mission trips and
uniforms for a little league team are
these are these things tithing
or does it only count if you give to a
church or religious religious
organizations
it feels so good to help and show thanks
for the work people do
but we would like to know where this
falls in our monthly giving
that's a great question syndi i mean the
the technical term for the tithe is
giving a tenth and specifically to your
local church so
if you want to get legalistic about it
with direct um
phrases and direct terms uh that is what
the tithe is so technically donating to
your a little league team is not a
technical tithe
but if you just want to say hey you know
i we want to give 10 as a family and
we're going to give that to these things
and that's going to be our giving for
the month
then that's totally up to you but as a
for me personally in our family as an
evangelical christian we tithe and then
anything above the tithe uh that we give
to these things that you've listed uh or
other things that we're passionate about
we give above the tithe but we
personally
give that 10 to the local to our tour
the church that we attend
uh but again if that's not your
conviction or your spiritual walk uh
giving in any capacity is something that
we recommend because
you
experience
this level of
selfishness in our world right that
everything is focused on me and when you
give and open your hands there is a
selflessness that's created and so
that's the goal in all of this to know
that hey
we're opening our hands we are not
holding and hoarding money and we're
letting money flow and regardless of
where we are financially giving is going
to be part of our story and so how you
do that really comes to your own
personal values and personal convictions
yeah so
when you say tithe
if you just mean generosity
and you're not a person of a certain
faith
then
then this is perfectly fine
you know if you just are substituting
the word tithe for generous it happens
to be 10 of your income that you're
being generous from but the tithe is a
religious term
technically and it would apply to
uh primarily evangelical christians
observe the tithe and prime and orthodox
jews and so um you know that and and in
both cases we're following scriptures uh
that give us an indication that we're
supposed old testament uh indications
that the tithe goes to the storehouse
and the storehouse in the old testament
had two primary goals and that was to
feed the widows and orphans and to feed
the levites which were the pastors the
priests
and um and so that's your local church
and that's where that teaching comes
from and why evangelical christians and
why orthodox jews of you know of most
ilks they're certainly nuanced that give
a tenth of their income but never even
even properly observed within those
religions it shouldn't be legalistic
it shouldn't be like god loves you
because you tithe or he hates you
because you don't that's just not true
uh there's nowhere in scripture that
says that but there is a lot of
scripture that talks about giving and
about generosity and about tithing and
it's because of what rachel was talking
about god is trying to teach us to be
less
uh selfish
and more other centered and giving does
that it shifts you it changes your
character
and that's why giving people who are
generous have a tendency to prosper
because they end up having an other
centered character and they're very
attractive
in that regard but uh you know we don't
ever want to get real technical but the
technical you know if you're gonna do a
bible study on it because you go to a
church
an evangelical church then that's what
you would probably hear and i would
agree with but i don't impose that on
say my muslim friends uh the tithe is
not in the koran
that i can that i know of unless one of
you muslim friends wants to teach me
about it but i've had a lot of fun
discussions with you and i don't think
it covers that the koran hates debt i do
know that uh big time uh and usury big
time but uh uh but i don't think there's
a tithing mandate there uh but so anyway
you know what what that amounts to is
are you defining that as generosity and
10 of my income is just going to
generosity and i'm not a person of faith
that
is a church attender or a synagogue
attender then yeah that's perfectly fine
what you're doing is great yeah giving
is you're never gonna maybe no i'm gonna
say never but seldom are you going to be
generous and look back on it and regret
it the only time you regret it is if you
figure out you gave to something you got
scammed but yeah
and i've had that happen but but oh they
didn't really have a need did they
yeah well yeah that's different but uh
that means i got some work to do in my
giving process but uh uh but by and
large yeah it does feel good to help and
show thanks to the for the work people
do i agree with you cindy and and we
want to encourage you to do that the
very first line on your budget sheet in
every dollar or if you get the old
sheets out of the backs of the books
i've written over the last 30 years
there's always budget sheets in there
the very first line is always giving
it's always generosity it's always
charity it's always a line like that so
the very first thing you should do in
your budget is to allocate some money to
give because for a christian tithing is
off the top it's first fruits before you
do anything else and that's just the
tithe to your local church now that's a
great discussion though um so
i just gotta kind of interpret what she
meant in the email and where she's
coming from
but you know good stuff good stuff
colton is with us colton is in spokane
washington hi colton what's up
hey dave hey rachel how you doing
better than we deserve how can we help
so i'm calling
my wife and i are almost to baby step
three we are
uh just a couple thousand dollars left
to pay off and we i just accepted a new
job
in um tennessee so my company is going
to
reimburse me for
my move
but we currently don't have the money to
make the move
they're not going to actually give me
the reimbursement until
a week or two after i get there so have
you asked them to advance it because you
don't have the money
yeah we talked about that and they they
said that there was with the policy ever
for the government you know whatever the
policy that they had in place they
weren't going to authorize that for me
okay so what if what have you got to
move
um we have a
four bedroom house and uh two vehicles
which we'll end up probably just driving
ourselves
um so and then our five kids
yeah you put them in the vehicles
yeah okay so you've got some furniture
to house you got some furniture to move
out of a four bedroom house
we have some furniture to move and we
have we have a pretty uh you know pretty
good deal with uh movie moving company
already
we have
um have that in place i feel like it's
gonna be cheaper than like a u-haul or a
u-pack kind of deal
so that just leaves basically so much
gas and
what's that how much does it cost
for them for the movers yeah
um
you see that the quote that we got was
uh about 4 500. and you got the money
you said
yeah we have the money we have the money
for uh we paid we paid half of that
a few months ago we booked it in advance
and then we don't have we don't have the
remaining
but i don't think that we don't owe them
that until after we get there
until after you get to tennessee or
after you get the reimbursement
until after yeah once once we get to
tennessee like we'll we'll get a bill
for the remaining so so that part yeah
is fine okay i mean i'd sell a bunch of
stuff is what i do and then i go work
like extra all you need is gas to drive
some cars to tennessee dude you're there
you can do it
it sounds like 2 000 bucks for the rest
of it yeah i mean go go go deliver
peaches for the next three weeks like a
crazy man
and
and have the large world's largest
garage sale and that'll lower your move
bill too because don't move a bunch of
this crap all the way across the country
it isn't worth the cost to move it most
of it
so that's the truth of all most of our
houses
that puts this hour of the ramsey show
in the books we'll be back with you
before you know it in the meantime
remember there's ultimately only one way
to financial peace and that's to walk
daily with the prince of peace christ
jesus dave here we just launched a brand
new audience survey for the ramsey show
and we'd love your feedback you could be
entered to win a
visa gift card no purchase necessary
take the survey at ramseysolutions.com
survey
[Music]
you